volunteer program dads and schools  officially on duty for the first time  today a handful of men were at lynch  elementary near lake mead and nellis  making sure parents and students got out  safely the principal requesting the help  from dads today  we chose today because historically  towards the end of the school year kids  the uptick in violence they want to  settle scores they think summer is  eternity and they're going to get away  with it and so we  we were just glad that today we didn't  see any violence any fights break out  there are about 400 men already signed  up as volunteers but the program needs  about 400 more that will help cover the  81 schools asking for help you can apply  on the dads and schools website